[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there we go good morning everyone
welcome back to gamespot live i'm richie
and let's just jump right into it we are
playing some call of duty the alpha for
vanguard is up and i'm in a lobby so i'm
going to switch over to this
game mode for y'all to see here
bam just like that okay
wish me luck i got into one match
earlier
everything went smoothly
the uh we're just a little early that's
all
right how's everyone doing today
welcome back yes thanks for being here
everyone let's see how this goes
your first look at call of duty alpha
champion hill
the game mode is pretty cool
i only played that one match
uh it's pretty cool it's really fast
pace
i got my ass kicked but uh you know now
that i got
now that i played one match i'm ready
for another
hey josh thanks for being here josh
anderson what up what's up chat
all right let me know how i'm sounding
or if anything's too loud uh just let me
know how the audio settings and quality
is here's like the uh
what's called the hunger game screen
here
now we don't kill each other but we do
we do supply here we do loot up and
before the uh before the game starts
welcome to champion hill friends
how's the audio guys your team has a
whole bunch of lives
lose all your lives and you're
eliminated
last team standing wins
grab some gear at those buy stations
okay take our opponents get cash easy
support you can also grab some cash off
the ground
i think last time i would i could have
used the uav so i'm going to go for that
see if i can get some support here
no nothing like that okay full plates of
armor
i mean that'd be cool i'll take the any
age i can get
um so when i was shooting people you can
uh you can upgrade your gun like live in
game
so i'm looking forward to that oh look
check it out some other weapons
these are all the ones we saw in the
trailer nothing out of the ordinary for
world war ii
10 seconds until start time check it out
guys tax sprint slide these are this is
the modern warfare engine so we're gonna
be seeing a lot of you know stuff like
that which is cool with me but uh that's
very polarizing
like do you guys like messing with doors
and stuff or do you guys absolutely hate
that let me know
and wish me luck cause we're about to
start
welcome to champion hill and all other
teams for the win
[Applause]
is that a phony bony
phony baloney grenade i think so or no
it's just background noise
where are they dude
i got one
there's two
the steps are kind of quiet at least
mine are that's good
come on where's the other guy last time
i died right in there i'm scared to go
in there i'm right in the middle though
oh
you got 10 seconds cool armor plate
equipment automatically equips your
armor that's really cool
guys your mom is on like that that's it
okay on to the next match
let me know i mean that was really quick
but let me know what you guys think
initial thoughts first impressions
this is uh
this is happening
new team new opportunities
and please forgive any uh
or gameplay that you may see here today
i just happen to be oh there's someone
over there i just happen to be the guy
in the office with the alpha code
now but i love call of duty so um
i want to give you i want to give you
guys some good gameplay of course
upgrade my weapon look at that okay
fully loaded oh no they killed my friend
this background shooting is kind of
distracting
hopefully kill my friend again
as you see upgrading my weapon again
what is it just time based oh my
animation is there we go
it's like it's stuck
no no no he's to my left damn it all
right
you got 10 seconds
come on game watch there we go
there you go ten lives left
[Applause]
enemy took your line oh man they killed
my homie three times that's okay i see
why this would be much fun with like you
know playing with not random people but
that's okay i'm you know that could
happen to anyone just wish me luck
hopefully hopefully we can just get into
the next match anyway
you gotta step it up me and your mom oh
[ __ ]
that guy destroyed a wall just like in
the trailer cool
he just walked right through and then he
died
come on i know i'm kind of hiding back
here but
that
one why can't i reload
oh
another oh i need armor now or at least
[Applause]
you got 10 seconds
damn
got my armor back
that's it take that
okay
now we're moving up
you might want to hit a buy station
now we can upgrade i like the mp40s i
don't think i'll need a new gun
demolition here all the perks
double time ghosts
dang
i think i'm going to roll with ghost
i like ghosts as a perk in general
only 10 seconds left
spy plane i'll take a spy plane okay
wish me luck guys
next match is about to start
thank you for moving now you win yeah i
know i'm not an aggressive
style player but i gotta be you know i
gotta be for stream we gotta win it's
not that's out of my hands
gotta change the settings already goofed
up and reload
oh come on i had him in the head i had
him in the head how does the movement
feel good question
as i completely hit up on the stream
um to me it feels closer to
uh modern warfare which is what you were
asking
you got 10 seconds are we winning now
yeah because you can slide and stuff too
you know uh
play with doors
come on where is he can we win i was a
match i was a draw
someone in the chat mr grip straight up
says this is warzone
yeah it looks like warzone at dusk like
it's like a later time of day look at
this
now that's not a bad thing i that's
because i love war zone though
i'm gonna go this way your mom can go
the other way and they killed their mom
where the hell
hold on
no
goodness gracious
help
okay i thought i had a reload i didn't
he's right there
you bag team baker at ease smoke him if
you got him smoke him if i got him okay
time to to relax no that's not true that
can't be true
i am going to take his stg's
all right you guys
how are we feeling about it so far
we've seen thank you god he's down for
the count
yeah this is ps5 by the way
i appreciate you guys appreciate you
guys tuning in i know this may not be
your game but
i'm sure you're just curious to see how
this new game plays
this already looks better than cold war
says ryan alright i mean i agree but
once again you guys know my modern
warfare bias
they killed my friend already they
probably sniped them
that
upgrading my one
[Music]
hey okay i'm gonna get out of this
corner hey fox was wrecked
oh i like how they give you a live
update of the other teams competing
team fox was wrecked
whoa
that bounced off the rock okay that was
theirs
come on as soon as i stop aiming down
sides he's gonna round that corner i
know it
upgraded my weapon again for five
thousand bucks
you got tense okay i'm going for it oh
the second i go for it
why would you tune in yeah and people
are just serious you know and of course
i want them
people are curious to see how this is
whether or not they actually like cod
i'm sure they want they want their minds
to be changed but a lot of people feel
it's just the same thing every every
year
that's a good chance to resupply
so i we won that round look at
everyone's gone except me and your mom
okay i like the mpe 40 i'm going to
stick with
it um i did like okay i still have
ghosts cool they they
keep it
full armor
extra life yo i might i might i might
shoot that's an option i'll take it
bomb oh you know what if you save all
your money you can get like uh the v2
rocket i think i haven't seen it yet but
you know
what else do i sell money
yeah let's get some uh
i don't really use tacticals i noticed
so i'm gonna i'm gonna stick with
support let's buy plane let's go
wish me luck you guys
got
1911 there
you got 10 seconds
brandon in the chat is not a fan already
okay wish me luck
this is champion hill mode
it is a mix of gunfight and like vr you
know it's gunfight it's a gunfight
competition between like eight teams
i always go in that little corner
blood thirsty
bloodthirsty
uavs up i just noticed
fmj rounds let's go through the wall
baby
wow he sniped my head off almost
should have died
your mom saved me i don't think that'll
get old
ooh the mp40 and i
look a little jumpy right now
at the assist okay you got 10 seconds
oh they spawn behind us no don't do that
that's it
what modes does the alpha have this is
it this is currently the only mode i
think next weekend when the alpha opens
up to the beta
um
there'll be more modes i hope but i
don't i can't confirm that actually
yikes
thanks your mom
upgraded my weapon again let's go
i wonder how many times i can do this
last one standing team's counting on you
don't say that
honey
it's right over here
i knew it
lord
you got 10 seconds i cornered myself i
thought this was a tunnel
there he is
hey who's climbing a wall i don't know
get back out there third place okay well
that's what it looks like you guys
i guess we can spectate and see the
winners here while i catch my breath
no i don't think i want to see what
happens
let's just get into the new game
[Music]
well i'll wait for this timer look
evan in the chat
i appreciate you man
no zombies yeah not during the alpha
seconds left stay strong
uh show us my maneuvers
storm geezer you're too kind man that
was really nice i mean
to me it made a sale
you're
somehow
all right i've been eliminated i'm
scared to back out though you guys last
time i backed out of a lobby you know it
took me forever to get into a new one so
i'm gonna wait for the timer on the top
of the screen there the one that says
130
let's see what happens
um
i can watch it i'm gonna go watch it
with this guy
that's cool
well sort of i mean like
it's nice if you're really interested
or if your friends are in there
you can ping i forgot to um
to do that
what the hell
oh what
how did i
work over here
[Applause]
thanks for being patient y'all you want
to see some sniper gameplay
actually
um
i think there was only one sniper
there's one of
um
every gun there's a shotgun a revolving
shotgun which was new okay i'll try some
other guns good call good call
oh you are so close
i thought we were second that stinks we
were third though yeah
is this mode fun if you like gunfight
mode absolutely
um i like gunfight mode but i'll be
honest like after the modern warfare
beta i didn't really play it like if
someone wanted to play it and they were
like hey could we play gunfight i'd be
like yeah sure but
i didn't go out on my own and do it very
much and it sucks because they have
their own specific maps you know
and i love the small maps like super
small maps but
um
well it's not my mode not really
don't worry aim assist will save you
well let me actually speaking of that
let me see here um there was one
there was one thing i didn't like about
my controller i don't think i have time
to do it but it was way down here it was
like
tap to interact
yeah it was those settings it was like
you know i like the
what they call it
like the
oh forget it i like to quickly pick up
stuff off the ground by tapping square
and the wording is different in every
game
you want to play tarkov mode in uh
battlefield 24
it sounds
lose all your lives and you're
eliminated
last team standing wins okay i'll try
out a new gun for you guys let's see
grab some gear at those buy stations
eliminate your opponents to get more
cash
perks um you can also grab some cash off
the ground
[Music]
here are the weapons
oh you guys i can't they have the car 98
which is cool um
i only have money for the stg so i'll
try that
um and then next round when i get more
money i will
buy a sniper
hate on cod just because yeah that's a
group of people that's cool i mean
it's it's crazy you know millions of
people love it millions of people are
like no not for me
just 10 seconds until start time
please do not shoot me
all right wish me luck guys
oh yeah sorry if i missed it this is ps5
gameplay
they have that lousy exclusivity deal
i thought that was over during the
champion hill
xbox 360 days you know i guess not dude
oh i saw him he's over there to my left
i saw him for sure
oh come on man
now we got to do to my right okay
surrounded
bad start bad start
that looks like my gameplay are you sure
that wasn't me
and he got me
fall down get back up again i see him
over there okay he's really far
hold on i hear foots footsteps that
aren't mine
f yep get ready to tap your ass you guys
because this is looking good
the shooting in the background is really
distracting that stinks
check it out guys i can slide and i can
text you got 10 seconds come on all
right i'm gonna quit playing here
oh they got my friend again you might
get eliminated early enemy took your
lives
alien fire team looks better than this
you know that's fine
i want to play that too
new match new team new opportunity let
me get this money
we can mount
yep yep confirmed
that
one first blood
no no no
he's up there on the roof yes
this is corn health
oh an extra life
good to know good to know you guys are
playing this that golden coin in the
middle
some
dang
it come on el patron help me out here
we're going to corner this dude what up
he vanished he slipped from our fingers
come on show your face
at least we got the the win on that one
kenny in the chat says i'm getting
sleepy from this gameplay
thanks for being here brother
team george has been sacked
cm punk i'm seeing that a lot i think
he's a wrestler right you guys can talk
amongst yourselves about all of that
because i don't
i've watched a while
money
through a grenade right here
they killed my friend
free coin
i clipped through the wall that's not
good
oh my god
i'd love to see this replay did he clip
through the wall too he just outgunned
me
look at me he's sitting there like hmm
yeah now arthur morgan in the chat is
yelling cm punk to the rest of the chat
careful there you go under 10 lives left
oh don't remind me
okay you've got 10 seconds
hey will you show the mounting mechanic
sure
anything to distract me from continually
dying careful there you go ten lives
left enemy took your lives hard l drop
your apps in the chat
arthur morgan is a very big fan of cm
punk
great
stock up while you can all right let me
try another gun here it's gonna get
worse you guys i swear you want me to
snipe i'll snipe
you thought that game play was rough
well
here we go oh interesting uh mechanic
with the uh
around the lens you know that weird
glassy look let's see how it goes only
10 seconds left
the 1911 op if it's a three shot kill
that's a good gauge you're right but i
don't think it will be
enough
okay cool wish me luck guys
how are the visuals compared to the cold
war they're more like 2019 modern
warfare uh
if i do say so myself just in general
that doesn't mean better or worse that's
how i that's what i thought of when i
saw this
they killed my friend
they're gonna kill me next
there he is
what did i tell you oh look
with um come on come back out
oh the aim down sight is slow
hey i didn't even hear that was i
stunned i think i was stunned yeah i
didn't even hear his footsteps at all
look at that wait i didn't hear his gun
go off either hmm
people are already slide cancelling i
bet yeah only four lives left i am not
that type of player you got 10 seconds
but
of course of course it's the thing if
you can slide you can slide cancel you
know
okay i crack their armor i gotta go for
the head i don't see this is what i was
afraid of with um snipers okay we're
last
easy
oh because it's uh
alphabetical
why why would this thing easy
can i switch to my old gun nope
yeah see as you can see you can kick
through doors
it's over dudes
[Applause]
not one but i need to breathe and that
person's coming for me coming for blood
little scope
little scope
doesn't matter
okay
well the beta should be live i am going
to just back out i'm not going to
spectate this time
thank you guys for being here another
call of duty already yeah it's that time
of year mr k
yeah we did get stunned anakin skywalker
in the chat okay good good i'm not crazy
i'm just bad
[Music]
let's see here all right
[Music]
yellow in the chat says this is better
than cold war already
any of you guys i mean it's been so hard
to get a
playstation 5 but
um
i think i don't know can someone you
guys know if this is a
uh exclusive not just for the five like
can you do this on ps4 as well if you
pre-ordered i should know this but
um
i was lucky enough to get the
playstation 5 that's what i'm playing
with today
they changed my character that's not who
i picked
there we go that's that's weird how it
just heard me but okay
hey michael
can you show weapon mods um i do them as
soon as they're available you just hit
uh right on the d-pad
and it it upgrades for you i don't think
it tells you in detail what happened
it'll say like leather strap you know
for your for your handle or it'll say
like scope but
that's it welcome to champion hill
friends there's no specific there's no
um
your teammates
weapon upgrades lose all your lives and
you're eliminated
last team standing wins
grab some gear at those buy stations ooh
van garden your opponents when you get
walking where should i spend my money
that's up to you guys grab some cash off
the ground betas are four i hope once
this opens up this will open up to
everyone soon
so i hope you get a chance to play and
you'll be able to make that decision up
for yourself i will
i definitely want to play both this year
[Applause]
works okay you can slide you can attack
sprint you guys saw that
you can mount if i do it right i need a
correct place to mount but you can
just 10 seconds until start time
the tommy gun we haven't tried that yet
ooh so chilled hey welcome back so
chilled he says remove sliding and call
of duty sliding and hopping yeah
i'm okay with sliding it's not really it
never really benefits me but hopping
around i hate that's just me championing
like a geezer
i always think i always say like black
ops 3
started allowed people to jump so much
like this isn't halo broke but jumping
around jump shotting shouldn't be a
thing in my opinion and that's what i
get for saying that
the timing gun
[Applause]
okay i got one take his armor real quick
armor gets uh immediately equipped
that's really nice you don't have to
equip it like warzone
i was mashing triangle as soon as i
started i was like oh come on
hold my friend
mount look at that
i got one but then i didn't die but my
homeboy went out there
new match new team new opportunities
i missed the guy i was playing with
earlier his name was your mom we did
well together
dude dude was hanging out up there
careful there you go under 10 lives left
oh don't rub it in man we're gonna
be rough here i see him
not one
there's yeah you can destroy some stuff
like watch this i'll destroy that wall
there
you got 10 seconds
up here yes i can
nope that was a stupid idea but we
retired
jerry a in the chat haven't touched a
call of duty game in years
i see there's no change to that trend
well i mean thanks for stopping by i
wasn't planning to change your mind but
you know you're interested
raffle
they killed my friend
oh they killed me
dude i gotta figure this out here
something's gotta change here
hey he has a bar was that an stg looks
like a bar
hmm
okay only four lives left
i want a bar i'm gonna upgrade this
weapon right now
no
slate reflector okay so it's a new site
you got 10 seconds team fox was wrecked
team fox was wrecked
i got one i don't think we i don't think
we won oh we did
yeah moving on to the next one
michael cobbs in the chat this game is
going to be better than anything out
later this year good luck spider-man wow
bold claim man
i want to hit a buy station well we made
it to the next match you guys saw how
badly i did with the sniper so i'm gonna
try with a
oh it's a three-line rifle
i wanted the bar i'm going to try the
bar
i hope it's not like
slow um what's it called
10 more seconds fire rating is that slow
okay
wish me luck
it's literally got the same font
has which game i can't tell
why do i always keep going in that
corner all right
i see him
the bar chugs this was a bad idea i knew
it i shouldn't have done that i
shouldn't have picked up the bar
only six teams remain
behind me behind me he's behind me i see
him on the uav
[Applause]
well how are we doing can i check the
i can't see how we're doing dang it
you got 10 seconds only four lives left
mount check it out
of course i unmount and there he is
there we go that's what i'm talking
about man okay
yeah
maybe it was a good idea the bar is
actually my friend maybe i need slower
um
you know
fire rate
they killed my friend
oh my god
is this on both xbox and playstation no
currently this is an alpha build and it
is on playstation exclusively
i think in the next few weeks
a beta for everyone to play or more
people to play
upgrade that boy yeah here i go good
call i'm sure eric that's gotta be too
long oh they're giving me a steady now
they give me a scope huh these maps are
kind of big so this might be helpful
you got ten seconds
look at that
eric the voice of god eric tay help me
out
can't breathe
enemy took your life oh no if i got one
more kill we could have moved up
oh well
let me get a gut check how do you guys
feel about
i mean despite my my gameplay how does
this look to you guys
stock up while you can i figure you're
here for a reason you want to see some
call of duty but
are you interested are you on the fence
are you like hell no
oh dude
auto loading shotgun a three line i'm
curious about this three line rifle and
this this is probably a machine gun oh i
know what this one is this is the big
one with the star trek ammo on top you
know what
that one's also slow i might go some
close range here what do you guys think
we'll see
see
perks i like ghost
we can get more perks
tracker i like that
i need my intel i'm a recon guy
i got a lot of money there we go full
armor
has been bagged four teams remaining
skid spot you got ten seconds they're
celebrating yeah this i'm getting
obviously i'm getting uh world war ii
vibes
same same developer that's cool
wish me luck
patrick in the chat says looks very bad
all right for sure for sure you are
entitled to your opinion friend
what the
reason i get stuck up why
i am out of grenades they were helpful
a bouncing betty i don't want to be that
guy
and i'm not that guy with as far as um
as far as uh throwing knives i can never
land a throwing knife
all right guys wish me luck
i'm gonna upgrade this again
okay
michael with the hot take this is gonna
be better than battlefield actually
i'm so excited for a battlefield
uh and this as well it's nice to finally
get some hands on with this
i'm hiding i'm just hiding like um
[Music]
i upgraded it somehow
a reflector oh i got a sight on this
no they're shooting my friend
you black team hal struggle's over
take a minute oh i won
why did
it only took one kill oh they were out
of lives it's life based
well we win let's see uh what do you got
here
he has a bar just like me upgraded
he has auto loading shotgun just like me
you got 10 seconds all right wish me
luck we're moving on to the next one
yeah dr merrill it is it is the modern
warfare engine they said it themselves
we uh we had like a presentation with
sledgehammer and they told us all about
the game like a few weeks ago and
it is the modern warfare engine my
friend
what about it doesn't look like it to
you
or why do you not believe that let me
know
the discussion is open
[Laughter]
can i do it
i smoked them
one life left your lips
peeking out my head like that oh the
other guy
standing it's on you soldier on me are
we down to our last life toast i'm
scared help me out
no respawning this is it
i'm stuck in this corner again
slide
nope i'm not gonna peek my head out that
much i hear him huh
you got 10 seconds
red barrel
oh i think we lost enemies
well i had i would have had to get i
would too
i would have had to have gotten two
kills to move us up
that was freaking out and we could
see here well there's a chance to
resupply
there's no zombies in alpha that's
correct unfortunately i would love that
because it's going to be developed by
treyarch this year
they're sticking with zombies it's great
double time survival training high alert
high alert scares the [ __ ] out of me i
can't deal with that
let's see what else i can get
support
full armor here and a spy plane
gotta have that intel
machine pistol hmm
nope i can't i already
i'm set up here i'm set up
crap lunchbox is my teammate
find an extra life yeah i will um
i'll try to do that they're always in
the middle of the map though i'm scared
i'm just too scared to be playing this
keep going better days
does anyone else have lower resolution
on the other hand
all right guys wish me luck here we go
yeah no zombies yet unfortunately
bro what is your feeling
so far it's okay i wish there were other
modes
uh i'm uh
see i like you know
team deathmatch and uh domination myself
i already did all this why didn't they
make me buy again
i'm going to save my money
yeah i'm already literally 10 seconds on
the club
there we go i'll upgrade it into what i
have already
okay here we go
infinite gamers in the chat do you think
this will be better than cold war
[Music]
i'm hopeful
okay
i won't be any i won't be getting any
better at all with my skill but
you're the last hope out there
these dudes are aggro they're coming for
me
right here watch
team's eliminated take a breath and get
back out oh we got second
dang it okay last time you were so close
shut up last time we got third we got
second this time
see we were
i had shots on him but he had better
i saw my bar go up into the left and i
missed the last shot
terrible terrible terrible let's go for
a dub come on
let's try again
hide in the chat says i love fps i used
to love fps games on console till they
brought uh kb m to it now i'm only
playing on pc
[Music]
yeah they're gonna um oh where are you
in the chat
[Music]
how will they implement this world war
two theme into warzone they're gonna do
it man
i'm gonna do it somehow
more colorful than modern warfare 2019
or the same i would say it's actually
like
there's like one big map so far and it's
i would say it's like
maybe even less colorful like but like
moody you know it was intentional
kind of drab you know every time they do
world war two it's not like bright and
beautiful um at least not in games
dr merrell with the hot take in the chat
that's okay man i mean
it's cool to feel that way
oh i wish everything didn't sound so
bassy interesting that's how i felt
about cold war everything was like just
bass bass they couldn't
i don't know i'm not i'm not in sound
design but i heard what i heard the
champion hill friends
your team has a whole bunch of lives
lose all your lives and you're
eliminated
last team standing wins
grab some gear at those buy stations
yeah eliminate your advanced optical
sights in world war ii yeah as soon as i
saw that in the trailer i had to do it
also grab some cash off the ground they
admitted it right away the developers
were like hey you know you want to
respect
they said we're not beholden to history
which is good which means they can have
some fun like you don't see hollow sites
in world war two no no you don't
uh but for the sake of gameplay you know
they wanna they want to have some fun i
guess
this game straight up looks like
[Applause]
i've heard that in the chat
thank you tom he says good luck okay i'm
gonna need it
went from third to second trying to get
the dub this time
it really it's no i mean
because really you know
you can lose lives your teammate can
lose lives and it's their fault
um
over and over again you know
[Applause]
oh he killed my friend
[Applause]
there's the one up in the end in the
corner over there
no
ah right in the face
solid boss says the movement is
identical to modern warfare 2018 it's
the same engine uh yeah you can mount
and everything and
tactical sprint um so yeah they are
using those features for sure for sure
for sure
that's it
wow
the guy on my team actually really
helped me out this time
got us through all right
how do dual sense features feel in the
modern warfare engine i turned them off
um it felt normal i tried them for like
a second
and then i was like oh yeah i don't like
this
you know what i'm gonna focus here
[Applause]
[Applause]
you can bust through the wall so you can
shoot walls like this but i'm not going
to i want to draw attention to myself
upgrade my weapon
we're shooting through that wall see
i'm hiding like a baby
there we go
[Applause]
you got 10 seconds
dude this guy on my team is carrying us
well i got one kill that's cool
uh but he got three like
i need this dude on my team
modern warfare expansion pack you know
that's not a
that's not a
uh unfair criticism
uh but i love modern warfare so that
makes your boy happy
oh
oh
upgrade my weapon
upgrading it again and i'm getting out
of here there he is no he threw a
grenade over there
oh i got sniped oh no oh no
i'm moving for a sec i'm not moving for
a sec sorry i'm out of the way
there we go
they're just lobbing grenades over here
oh that's my right
hand
you got 10 seconds you got five lives
left
is that a human
enemy took your life dang it
my bad my bad and level four
red dot in world war ii setting yeah
classy x
stuck up oh yeah
okay my teammate is is good so i'm
hoping he carries us to victory i just
want you guys to see it
let's see here i like tracker and i like
ghost
please hold your fire
um
no
10 seconds left stay strong
upgrade this again and i got the m10
brake i don't know what that is see
hopefully just means my guns better oh
it's the muzzle brake okay
oh wish me luck
merrill
can i slide cancel no i
i don't even know how
i'm not that i'm not you know
not mlg
only six teams remaining
oh crap i fell off okay
okay
got one
you need to breathe
just like the game
yeah yeah
okay you got 10 seconds
uh i wish i could slide cancel for you
for reals
i don't apply that in my gameplay i
don't know how to and i don't want to
i'd probably just do it wrong
sammer plays as asking the question
what do you guys think about all of this
the hunter i like it he's my friend
uh
footsteps
don't know how that happened but i'll
take it
how many times can you upgrade your
weapon probably like eight
oh which i can't i can ping hold on i
forgot how though
that's not a pain how it's down and out
okay
good ease
you've got ten seconds team able was
eliminated four teams remaining it's
getting spicy
right take a breather you lot um
yeah all right cool cool that's it take
their lives
looks like we are team fox and we have
four lives left and team baker has 11
lives
oh
oh dear
these guys are hungry
and i threw this grenade at myself
i see him
oh come on i had him up
his head
right now we're down to two lives
i need the ultimate clutch but
tracker is great it helps me
[Applause]
you've got 10 seconds one life
that's it take their lives
um what
i need i need to iron out the rules of
this mode because i thought we just lost
straight up
well there's a chance to resupply let's
go then
we'll probably see
okay
so does baker team have to fight
team easy now
we each have one life
we got one more life all right that's
cool
double time survival training pretty
amazing you got 10 seconds
we didn't tell
spy plane extra life i'll buy it yeah
full armor good good good okay well
let's see here
toothy in the chat this game looks
pretty whack
that's
fine it's okay
you have a voice here stock up while you
can
infinite warfare oh we're seeing
infinite warfare in the chat all right
oh infinity ward uh yes and infinite
warfare okay
i like i like i dub and i like uh
warfare didn't feel like in the story it
didn't feel like a cod game but it was
cool
made a video all about it i played them
all guys
played every call of duty made two
videos about it
here on gamespot.com
wish me luck
can't upgrade my gun anymore
through the wall through the wall not
through the wall my rounds were on fire
i'm scared i'm so scared
damn it
yo this dude's got the drum mag
all right
uh they put me in a really bad only two
lives steady now
[Music]
one life left to live make it count
freaking out freaking out
random nade
that dude had all the armor in the
world oh
take my money and run
help help
oh he's on my channel for sure oh [ __ ]
no
what the heck
is his teammate back his teammate is
back
i don't know why i thought it was 1v1 of
course they had like 12 lives left
you were so close
oh my god i'm on fire and everything
that was embarrassing
oh well
i like gunfights so i'm i'm having fun
with this mode i just want to get the
dub
for you guys today i want to see what it
looks like
excuse me
so we'll try again
we're getting there i got second place
twice
dbx in the chat says what do you guys
think of this game it looks okay in my
opinion
mr j right after just says
[Music]
looking to get a dub
why does the captain speak so damn much
yeah
it's the dude from um
excuse me it's the dude the same dude
from like the gun bench right from world
war ii or whatever was called the
gunsmith
the one who's always like
get the lid out of your boots whatever
i'm not going to do that impression
again
but you know it was war mask you know
the guy i'm talking about same voice
actor
not a fan of the world war two setting
that's fair
i was surprised it was a rumor remember
when um
vanguard was just a rumor
i was like no they're not gonna do that
are they welcome to champion hill
friends
here we are your team has a whole bunch
of lives oh my god i'm playing with i
like your coach
i feel it last team standing with feel
it
grab some gear at those buy stations
eliminate your opponents to get more
cash
grab some cash
you know i'll stick with the mp40 if i
upgrade it i think it'll be fine
and save my money for something else
yeah there we go
[Applause]
you have one of those okay i think i'm
ready
wish me luck guys
[Applause]
i also wanted to turn up the center 10
seconds
[Applause]
spring cancel reload
okay we'll get into that later
welcome to champion hill uh i really
regret using them before wait
because the scg is better long range of
course of course
they do grenade at us
oh
my armor
i like you cut g help me out
i'm gonna go slap your head because we
gotta go bald
[Applause]
oh
tax prank is back
swore i saw something
oh
i got one
okay
upgraded it two times in a row let's go
you got ten
seconds oh they killed my friend again
that's it take their lives
okay
yeah it's the modern warfare 2019 engine
that's true
new match new team new opportunities
money
all right i'm gonna go
you go team up with i like to cut g
i see him over there
nice he got him
i got one
good good good
stupid idea to go right up there after
that idiot rgb
fight ain't over yet
fighting careful there you've got under
10 lives left
here
[Applause]
make another upgrade real quick go
who you fighting
you got 10 seconds
that's it take their life okay well
we're doing okay we're doing okay this
is champion hill mode thanks for
everyone tuning in i had a i had to
focus for a little bit but the call of
duty alpha is out now for playstation 5
if you pre-ordered the game and the only
mode available is champion hill mode
it's like gunfight
2v2 uh and battle royale it's like a
competition uh after we knock out one
group of two we move on to the next
group of two
best team of eight
takes the win
you have armor you can attack sprint
just like modern warfare you can slide
which is cool with me because i like
that
[Applause]
through the wall through the wall nope
nope not at
all cheap shot he's down for the count
don't know how the hell i did that
should have been
there we go that's more like it all
right
yeah it looks like the hunger games when
you start because you just there's this
big ass table of stuff
everyone playing surrounds it you know
you guys seen hunger games what the hell
that was a terrible fine
for that guy
for me
[Music]
how do you get xp
uh
do you get xp when you leave after
you've lost
uh for completion
if you don't leave early you get xp you
can also spectate but you don't have to
okay the mp40 is doing good for me so
i'm gonna i'm gonna buy a perk instead
perks
gotta have tracker gotta have ghost
and i need full armor that was very
helpful
it's my plan
yeah 10 seconds on the club you can buy
an extra life i just uh use my money
differently there so
fried chicken in the chat says i'm
loving this update to modern warfare
2019
uh it's not related to the original
world war ii from um
you know 2017 it's not
from that series at all
yeah good [ __ ]
tax break tax break let's go
that one
quick upgrade to the gun
upgrade my gun again let's go
just in time
you got 10 seconds
team george has been sacked four teams
remaining let's get spicy butt wipe was
that his name
that's it
seven's our lucky number all right all
right all right cool cool cool
maps 40 yards long
short range guns are king
so i mean i can't disagree this mp40 has
carried me through
uh so far
although someone was sniping earlier
look at that oh
lord
blasted that dude's armor off
on what was that i had shots
i'm gonna be like that guy he's one shot
he's one shot
only two lives steady now
where'd he go
oh lord
yes
bunny oh we throw a grenade i'm i'm
his footprints where'd he go oh he's
dead
good job i'd like you cut g my homeboy
over here yes
my dear friend
enemy took your lives no
i was like yeah we won and we freaking
lost
that match
but we get to try again after this buy
round suck up while you can
okay i need full armor again priorities
extra life i don't have enough money for
that
okay
you got 10 seconds nice work wrapping
that up
well that's about all i have enough
money for wish me luck friends full
armor and a fully upgraded mp40 okay
i realize the mic was right in my face
like in my way
it is a chance to resupply again i only
have 50 bucks
oh yeah i wanted to see how you ping
uh
settings
those like controls right controller
layout over here
thing is okay left on the d-pad i
thought i did that
i'm doing it right now and i can't it
doesn't work
maybe in-game it'll work
all right y'all wish me luck see him i
see him already
got one
ron burgundy iced
me dang
oh dude is tripping
this is i like your cut g this is my
friend
he's walking talking around
take a breath and get back out there yes
well victory
oh you are so close
they won victory we got second again
all right in his privates
bruh in the chat says modern warfare 2
remastered we need that
i would love that
like the
multiplayer
people are are torn on that though some
people are like yeah i need it i want it
and then others are like no that game
was a mess
let it have its moment in history and
forget about it
i would play it
yeah king of second place f please drop
your f's in the chat or just put two in
the chat because that's me
dang it
that one was a good match though a lot
of that was more kills than normal for
me
what would this game what would this
game be without bunny hopping yeah dude
not a fan not a fan
ghost ghost gaming with the with the hot
take in the chat
[Music]
all right here we go the mp40 was good
though i'm gonna try that again and i'm
gonna stop this spammer
there we go
none of that please what are you doing
that here for
tommy gun i want the mp40
yes thank you for the f's
trying to get first guys
is it good so far cars welcome to the
chat um it's pretty cool so far if you
like if you like a whole bunch 2v2
gunfight this is you lose all your lives
and you're eliminated
um standing wins sorry i kept talking uh
some gear at those buy stations over all
the mechanics your opponents to get more
cash they're like uh modern warfare
twenty-nine could also grab some cash
off the ground
if you like that game then this might be
for you or at least worth a shot because
uh the beta will be open for everyone
soon
let's see here yeah i'm broke i got no
more money
gotta earn the rest of my money here
can you use the shotgun okay um when i
get money
i ran out of money already but when i
get some money next match if i live i
would use the autoloading shopping thing
[Applause]
okay here we go
uh i miss my old teammate i like to cut
g
now i'm playing with
txe
or next
welcome to champion hill and all other
teams for the win
and them
here
[Applause]
jumpy jumpy this gun is jumpy
but it's weird otto picked
the thompson for me i wanted the mp40
but i don't know how that works
without buying it the mp40 i don't think
was even on the list
a bouncing betty
see uh
got one
all right all right
the other one's still in there
there
okay yeah aaron in the chat doesn't like
the uh
the 2v2 for alpha only they did that
with conor mcgregor uh modern warfare
2019 as well
um and i wanted i wanted 6v6 too but
okay i can break these but i don't want
to it's gonna it's gonna
waste bullets
there's someone over there
can i ping no pink it said that was the
ping button but it turns my gun into a
single shot i think
upgrading my gun real quick okay
check out this
not period correct
scope
oh man
he was to my left tommy gun kind of bad
yeah back into the fray soldier it's a
user error bro
it's like it always was it's a little
jumpy here
but it's got a lot of bullets and it
sprays fast
enemy took your life oh i was ugh
great
moving on next match
uh yes uh solid is snake in the chat
what up i am playing on ps5
it's only on ps5 right now there's a
like alpha build
that's only available if you pre-ordered
soon it'll open up to a beta for
everyone
oh goodness oh
i can't see
okay upgrading this gun again
dang it
up there
nope behind me oh oh goodness
[Applause]
that's a good point black ops one had
red dots although that was the like
weights yeah
no
ah
i shouldn't have got up so soon
shoulda coulda woulda hunt
it's a draw
yeah flex in the chat imagine thinking
about uh resupply historical accuracy in
call of duty games
fair assessment see what i'm saying i
mean if you
just want you know they just want people
to have fun
let's see here
support
or armor
i love me the spy plane i gotta do it
that's like my go-to so far
10 seconds on the clock
yeah
by the way ghost only works if you're
moving i learned that yesterday
at least that's what the people on
twitter were saying and i think i've
confirmed that today
wish me luck guys
money
i don't know how i got that but i'll
take it
okay cool cool
only six teams remaining you knocked out
team charlie we're done here stretch
your legs oh they were out of lives
they were out of lives entirely okay wow
feels good man
anakin skywalker welcome back to the
chat i can finally catch up a little bit
here am i liking it so far
it's like
the modern warfare engine in a world war
ii game like i'm cool with it so far i'm
not like
you know head over heels in love but
[Applause]
having fun
it's always exciting you know like i'm
it's good to have
it's nice to have this opportunity to
even try the new game
so in short i'm just happy to be here
guys
man maybe not anymore
i'm in this corner like
see because that guy was coming for me
i'm out of here
what happened to my uav
me and my friend are here okay all good
all good
yo i'm just going to keep upgrading this
gun it gives me the option
all right i'm going to move out no more
no more hiding
don't want to be too loud with my
footsteps
where'd they go
you got 10 seconds
team able was eliminated four teams
remaining let's get spicy enemy took
your lives what the hell they were they
were hiding out damn
should have gone after them
ah the walls lousy walls
there's the extra life
a rat
team george has been sacked
sacked
i'll take that extra live woohoo
they killed my friend oh
dude these guys like to to camp out
um
am i sucker for going
seeing what's up or should i camp out
too i'm scared
they are in there they're in their
positions
oh my god
you got 10 seconds
got one
[Applause]
well it was a tie i was not it could
have been worse i guess i'm glad i went
after it
okay the team in the lead has nine lives
out of 12 and we have five so this is
now we're facing off against them
shoot there were two of them right there
already bro
upgrading this gun all the way come on
come on
they see me for sure
i saw one run over here
yes i got one
bloodthirsty
no no
gameplay chugging you guys let me know
um i'll be able to
read the chat in a second here
damn
blind fire i'll try that oh yeah next
match if we make it through i wanted to
use the shotgun 10
seconds only four lives left
come on
oh yeah
that's it take that line yeah moving on
i'm using the thompson the tommy gun
forget what it's really called it's like
the m
two one i forget i don't even remember i
could even even even even even even
though it is a chance to resupply
first order of business
oh i don't have enough money for an
extra life
full armor spy plane i don't think i
have enough money for a shotgun i'm
really sorry i really want to get the
win oh look i do okay
great
okay priority there we go
tommy gun fully upgraded
okay
that's about all i can do wish me luck
battlefield just looks better so far
says cars
the bar is in the game
um for
flavio in the chat it is in the game
there were hollow sites in world war two
i know look at this thing
ah they weren't obviously but
you know
that behold into history is was their
terminology
oh man we have to fight against team h
well at least we're we both have four
lives this is a little more
i knew it i knew it
ah
okay freaking out but my thompson is
fully upgraded i'm ready to let's do it
there's the extra life in the middle
i'm scared
i'm freaking out you guys
come on
oh why am i reloading i have 57 bullets
left in the drum mag
forget it
[Laughter]
you got 10 seconds oh that was a
claymore tick
come on c7
and
so i've noticed the trend oh we at least
it's a draw uh the trend is people like
to
like
hold their ground in the later rounds so
they don't even have to like face off
with each other
it's a little scary
goodness
[Applause]
got one
his friend is around here somewhere
oh i saw him damn it i saw him and i
went for the run anyway dang it dang it
oh i can't see a thing oh my god that
was
and that's how we lost folks
wait what's going on you got 10 seconds
oh my friend has one life like my
teammate
he's using the ball
take a breath and get back out there we
need to go into this last round with as
many lives as possible
damn
third i thought we did second
back again in the chat no no with that
spam please no
no no advertising uh for sites like that
leave game okay let's try again
yeah don't worry peter peter i got you
that bot is gone
[Music]
let's try again yeah f i know
that was a rough end too that was a
rough end to the match i was really sad
about that because we were doing good
and just collapsed
yeah
okay i'm glad not the only one chat uh
they noticed how like my vision just got
like
so dark
uh when i got shot or maybe it was a
stun grenade i don't remember
but i couldn't even see the dude
and he was right there
thank you gamespot trailers thank you
eric for
blocking them
what's with the bar saying it's
chambered in 308 i don't know
historically inaccurate
just kidding i have no idea
all right well
they gave me the tommy gun again
i'm going to try another gun
i did okay with you has a whole bunch of
lives
lose all your lives and you're
eliminated
last team standing wins
grab some gear at those buy stations wow
you can really put this
you can also grab some cash off the
ground the bar i had some fun dumb luck
with that last time remember for those
of you who've been here from the start
um
the big ole lmg the three-line rifle
i have enough for the bars i'm just
gonna do it because i don't i don't
think i want the tom again this time
and that's all the money i have
gotta earn the rest
uh the alpha's been out just since this
morning
just 10 seconds until start time
uh it started at um a little early today
started at
like 9 30 it's just when i got my first
match they said 10 but
i got in a little early folks
in fact this is uh we're
it's 11 13 now i think
if all goes well champion hill should be
my last
[Applause]
what's going on over here
look at that all that [ __ ] and i
still didn't
i had
i had them to myself
and i didn't kill them that's that's
just
that's me
but they were just hanging out like what
happened
time to upgrade my bar oh i don't like
the scope
[Applause]
you've got 10 seconds
new slayer
team easy's been eliminated that's it
take their lives all right cool
well weird start
um those guys weren't even playing for
half of the match
wish
there we go you can mount
come on come through
why did i stop mounting at the ver
[Applause]
going for your armor brother
money
oh come on oh they were both there
[Applause]
you've got 10 seconds
cool got the assist great
that's it take their lives
we'll take that win i guess we are team
b team baker
captain price's voice no i don't think
that's him it's the gunsmith from um
world war ii i think you know the the
other sledgehammer game
i think it sounds like him to me
[Applause]
i'm hearing gunfire
got one
what oh that's my friend
oh
okay moving on moving on
come on shoot through cover right
now
right here here he comes
that one
oh goodness gracious great balls of fire
oh my armor is full good news good news
good news
oh
i've been stunned to film take their
lives but we'll take the win
reminds you of dying in campaign yeah
when the screen got all goofy yeah i
don't know about that man
i'm doing good with the bar so i'm gonna
keep the bar and i'm gonna focus on
buying perks and stuff you can buy a lot
of stuff
look at that full armor i think i
already have four armor let me check no
i don't not at all what the
full armor sure i'll take an extra life
i'll take that spy plane you can buy
perks too but i'm out of money look at
it
ghost
all right cool
are upgraded
good good wish me luck
again i'm getting to know the maps and
i'm a little more familiar with the maps
now
where's blood i'll take it hell yeah
someone's over there
all right
yep
it's down and out only six teams
remaining nice work wrapping that up oh
they have no wait they're out of lives
nope i see one over there i'm gonna get
out of this corner that's not fair i'm
not gonna be that guy
oh team hal was another um another team
in the running
[Applause]
slide thirsty you got 10 seconds
i'm flattered bloodthirsty
me
no no
oh my friend saved my life
that was sloppy i was trying to reload
upgrade my gun and i was getting shot at
whatever
we are moving on yes
is this game mode yeah it's the only one
in the alpha currently this game mode uh
champion hill is the only mode right now
oh i saw someone over there confirmed
did he get him
what the heck that was so oh i would
love to see that replay on my screen
that sounds kind of rough
whatever let's let's do it careful there
you go under 10 lives left team able was
eliminated
leather grip okay so i upgraded the grip
on this
thing
freaking out freaking out a little bit
oh killed my friend
you got 10 seconds
oh come on
we traded shots there
rough dude ruff
oh it's cool
i'd always say your name
hashreena in the chat says i might this
might be worth dusting off the old ps4
for that's cool
i hope so
um i just want you guys to have fun oh
no that just hanging out up there
oh
okay gun was upgraded
you guys see that weird particle effect
look at my look at my cursor
it's a little buggy
a little bit look at that
[Applause]
i hit him
oh no my my
my tactical
uh grenade glitched out too a little bit
my animation for that you know
where'd this guy go you got 10 seconds
that one
that's it take that long yeah that one
got it
resupply and stock up okay i'm gonna
upgrade the bar
much as i can
i got 500 bucks left
full armor oh an extra life is 3 000
bucks damn
[Applause]
all right going in on a armor pack and a
prayer that's all i got friends ten
seconds left stay strong
oh man these guys have oh
mmm
these guys have nine lives they're a
bunch of cats
got one
now they have eight
oh the extra life in the middle
yo is my team my teammate
awake
what the oh that's a
so
i'll give him this he's not camping
[Applause]
you around 10 seconds
[Applause]
blood thirsty
that's it take their lives okay well we
have to face them again because they
still have i think because they still
have uh six lives
oh
upgrading my weapon
to the max wish me luck you guys
four teams remaining skipped spicy you
eliminated team fox at ease smoke them
if you got
um
we did it fam um wow great
um with two lives left we've got
so now we just wait here because the
other team is still fighting each other
team charlie look um they have six lives
well it's good to know that the i'm
seeing here that the ps4
uh is also getting the beta which is
great because it's not easy to get the
ps5 right now so good that's
that's good
we've got 10 seconds
okay
that's it take their lives chad says
this looks like doo doo
do you have a favorite call of duty let
me know what
call of duty in your mind does not look
like doo doo if any
i like i like how modern warfare 2019
looked a lot
um and this is the same engine but it's
like you know set in world war ii
goodness gracious to our left or to our
right new slayer
make it count wow it's all up to noob
slayer we get to watch him
oh no i got one life left
one life left give it your all
[Applause]
that dude is sniping though
oh man
well please eliminate it take a breath
and get back out there oh fourth we were
doing so well
yeah even the voice actor is the same
that's correct from if you guys
recognize that voice from
you got 10 seconds my mic is falling
down
there we go
well
let's see it's about that time
let's see here
okay
i don't want to spectate that team so
let me check this out here
okey dokey my friends
um we're just gonna go ahead and call it
there let me switch over back to obs see
what's up say what's up to you guys
hey all right cool great thanks for
tuning in
could not get the dub in the stream but
i appreciate you guys for uh tuning in
and watching anyway having some fun
hopefully and i hope you're able to
check out the beta soon for yourself
uh it's currently actually an alpha it
will be a beta soon and it'll be open
for xbox players pc
and continually playstation 5 down the
line make sure to check out the dates i
believe we have an article over on
gamespot.com to check out all those
dates and when it launches
thanks again for watching you guys take
care and i'll see you next time
bye